ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะคือหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนนะคะก็กลับ
มาเจอกับเรา 2 คนนั้นในวีดีโอระดับอะไรคะ
ในวีดีโอระดับอีกอินเนอร์ค่ะช้างนักหลายๆ
รูปฟ้าวันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันเสาร์ค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
เดือนอะไรคะเมษายน
ปีพตอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
ดีคศอะไรคะปีคศ 2  022 ค่ะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะแต่เมื่อวานนี้วัน
ศุกร์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 1
เดือน
เมษายนปีพตต
2565 ปีคศ 2  022 ค่ะจะพรุ่งนี้วันอะไร
คะพรุ่งนี้วันอาทิตย์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 3 ค่ะเดือนเมษายน
ปีพตออก 5  6 ห้าปีคศ
2  022 ค่ะค่ะน้องแล้วตอนนี้เวลากี่โมง
คะตอนนี้เวลา
11:00 นกี่นาที
5 นาทีค่ะกับ 4 นาทีเนาะก็เดือนนี้เนี่ย
เป็นเดือนเมษายน
นะคะประเทศไทยเนี่ย
ร้อนใช่ไหมคะ
ร้อนมาก
[ปรบมือ]
หักผู้หญิง
พอค่ะเข้าใจแล้วว่าร้อนเนาะประเทศไทย
เนี่ยร้อนเดือนอะไรคะครูฟ้าประเทศไทย
เนี่ยร้อนเดือนมีนาคม
มีนาคมนะฮะ
เมษายน
พฤษภาคมค่ะ
กรกฎาคม
มิถุนายน
ธนายนต์ร้อนเดือน 3 เดือน 4 เดือน 5 ถึง
เดือนปีหน้าประเทศไทยเนี่ยร้อนกี่เดือน
ครูฟ้าตีเดือนค่ะเดือนสาย 4 เดือนเนาะ
เป็นฤดูร้อนในประเทศไทยแต่ประเทศนักเรียน
ก็มีฤดูน้อย
และให้นักเรียนต้องมีฤดูร้อนหรอร้อนจริง
ไหม
ไม่รู้
ประเทศไทยร้อนมากนี่เนาะไม่รู้ว่าประเทศ
นักเรียนกับประเทศไทยเนี่ยร้อนเหมือนกัน
ไหมแล้วประเทศนักเรียนเนี่ยมีฤดูร้อน
เมื่อไหร่
ถ้าเป็นอเมริกายุโรป
News ไม่ใช่ค่ะไม่ใช่ใช้อเมริกายุโรป
เกาหลีญี่ปุ่นหรอก็จะร้อนเนี่ยนะคะประมาณ
นะประมาณเนาะเดือนมิถุนายน
อาการกฎาคมแล้วก็
สิงหาคม
3 เดือนหรอน้องประเทศนักเรียนร้อนประมาณ
3 เดือน
นะสามเดือน
ประมาณสามเดือน
สายค่ะประเทศไทย The  4 เดือนใช่ไหมแล้ว
เวลาที่
ฤดูร้อนในประเทศนักเรียนนะไม่ใช่ประเทศ
ไทยนะอ่ะประเทศนักเรียนเนี่ยเวลาฤดูร้อน
ประเทศนักเรียนเนี่ยเราจะคิดถึงอะไรบ้าง
ล่ะ
รู้ร้อนในประเทศนักเรียนหรอเพลงชนะเลยละ
กันเวลาครูฟ้าเนี่ยได้ยินคำว่าฤดูร้อน
ประเทศไทยประเทศนักเรียนเนี่ยครูฟ้าคิด
ถึงอะไรอย่างแรกฤดูร้อนเนี่ยร้อนครูฟ้า
คิดถึงอันนี้อ่ะผู้หญิงแช่สกรีนได้ไหมคะ
อ่ะถ้า
คุณยังไม่ให้ผู้ฟ้าแชร์เหรอคะไอ้ห่ากูฟัน
ต้องแชร์ให้รูปมันอยู่ทางซ้ายมือนะเพราะ
ว่ามันหน้าจอมันไม่เห็น
ออนก็จะแท้อันนี้เชิญค่ะครูฟ้าครูฟ้าคิด
ถึงอะไรในฤดูร้อนต่อแชร์จอโอเคโอเคค่ะครู
ฟ้าอ่ะคิดถึง
กูฝ่าวาดวัดแค่ตรงนี้นะแค่เส้นอะไร
โอเคค่ะใครคะครูฟ้า
แน่นักเรียนรู้หรือยังคะอะไรเนี่ยรู้ไหม
รวยหาคืออะไร
รู้เรื่องอะไรนะเพลงกำลังชิดค่ะคืออะไร
อ๋อ
นะค่ะอะไร
นักเรียนรู้แล้วเอาไอศครีมไง
ๆสมัยฤดูร้อนก็ต้องคิดถึงไอศครีม
ไอศกรีมยิ้ม
เรียนก็กินไอศครีมหรือว่าไอติมก็ได้นะเลข
2 ใหญ่ค่ะคนไทยพูดไอติมไอติมจะเป็นอย่าง
นี้ไหม
เหมือนกันนะคะอะหรอ
ไอศครีมแต่ว่าอันนี้เป็นไอติมแท่งสมัย
ไอติมแท่งส่วนที่ครูฟ้าวาดรูปที่ 1 เนี่ย
เป็นไอศครีมโคนดูนี้เป็นไอศครีมที่เป็น
แท่งไหนมีไม้แล้วก็จะน้องคิดถึงไอศครีม
ครีมผู้หญิงไปช่วยมากเป็นชอบไหมชอบค่ะใช้
ฤดูร้อนเนี่ยอากาศอาจจะ
40 สมัยองศาเซลเซียส
พี่ฟิล์มเนี่ยมันเย็นใช่ไหมกินแล้วจะรู้
สึกแบบตื่น
ดีว่าซะครูฟ้าได้หาให้รู้ว่า Stop ใช่ไหม
อิอิไม่สต๊อกอีกนะช้างพี่ช้างไม่ใช่ถึง
อันนี้หรอไอสัสไม่ได้ไอศครีมฤดูร้อนเนี่ย
นี่หาครูฟ้าเค้าต้องคิดถึงพระอาทิตย์การ
แสงแดดเห็นไว้ว่าอะไรยูว้อนใช่ UV ก็ PA
+  +  + สมัยขาแสงแดดเนี่ยฤดูร้อนเห็นก็
รอแล้วนะเห็นแล้วก็ร้อนมากนะไม่ดูหล่าพ่อ
มีแสงฮะ
เวลาเราหรือเร็วร้อนเนี่ยเราต้องระวังแดด
นะไม่พอมีแสงแดดใช่ไหม
ถ้าเราก็ต้องมีแว่นกันแดดสวิตซ์อะไร
ผู้หญิงอะไรคะลูกค้าใส่แว่นค่ะแต่ครูปลา
ไม่ได้ใส่แว่นกันแดดกริ่งก็ใส่แว่นมีค่ะ
ครูฟ้าแล้วกูว่าจะใส่แว่นกันแดดได้ไงต้อง
มาใส่แว่นกันแดดก็จะมองไม่มี
ใส่แว่นกันแดดเข้าไปเป็นของแว่นล่ะถึง
แว่นค่ะอุตส่าห์อุตสาห์ฟ้าต้องใส่แว่น 2
อันก็คือแว่นสายตาสวยแว่นที่เราใส่เนี่ย
เป็นแว่นสายตาจะได้มองเห็นแต่พอเวลามา
ร้อนไม่มีแสงแดดเนี่ยมี UV เราใส่แว่นสาย
ตาแล้วมองเดี๋ยวโอ๊ยไม่ได้
เราก็ต้องใส่แว่นกันแดดผู้ฟ้าก็ใส่แว่น
กันแดดอีก 1 อันก็ใส่แว่นของอ่ะ
วงเซเว่น
แต่ผู้หญิงมันจะเหนื่อย
โอเคเออหรือไม่ครูฟ้าก็ต้องมีแว่นที่มัน
แบบเคยเห็นไหมที่มันจะเป็นแค่แว่นอย่าง
เดียวลูกค้าก็มาใส่ที่นี่อ่ะเวลาคุณป๊าจะ
มองแดดก็ใส่เวลาครูฟ้าเข้าบ้านก็เอาออก
แต่นักเรียนใช่ไหมฤดูร้อนในประเทศนัก
เรียนและนักเรียนใส่แว่นกันแดดคนไทยใส่
ไหมคนไทยไม่มายไม่ค่อยใส่ทำไม่ใช่เนาะเออ
ไม่ร้อนหรอคนไทยไม่รู้นะคนไทยไม่ชอบใส่นะ
คะอ่ะแล้วก็มีแว่นกันแดดครูฟ้าคิดคิดได้
อีกไหมคะ
คิดถึงอะไรคะครูป๊าผู้หญิงจะให้กูฟ้าแชร์
scream
ครูฟ้าอ่ะ
ถ้าพูดถึงฤดูร้อนเนี่ยครูพระคิดถึง
อะไรอ่ะ
เล่นสีฟ้านะคะลูกหญิงจะรู้ไหม
ไม่รู้อะไรเนี่ยเครื่องยัง
ไม่รวยฮ่าอะไหล่ภูเขาหรอคะ
ครูหญิงหาผู้หญิงไม่รู้เหรออายุคืออะไร
อะไรอ่ะคะครูฟ้า
สระว่ายน้ำ
เฮ้ยผู้หญิงฆ่าเวลา
อามีน้ำใช่ไหมเราก็กระโดดลงไปแล้วก็ว่าย
น้ำน้องทรีสไตล์ผีเสื้อผีเสื้อเป็นไง
ผีเสื้อไม่รู้นะแต่พี่เลยอ่ะกบ
มาหาสระว่ายน้ำ
ใช่ว่าเราต้องมีสระว่ายน้ำนะคะอันนี้อะไร
คะโดนัทคู่ห่วงยางสวยใสที่นี่แล้วก็แบบ
มันก็ว่าไงเพราะอากาศร้อนเนี่ยเราก็ต้อง
ว่ายน้ำใช่ไหมจ่ายค่ะครูป๋าก็อยู่ที่นี่
ใช่ไหม
เราก็ยังห่วงยางได้มีห่วงยางห่วงยางใช่ๆ
ค่ะสระว่ายน้ำเนาะพ่อครูฟ้าเนี่ยคิดถึง
สระว่ายน้ำอ่าสต๊อกสต็อกอ่ะอ่ะ
โทรหา
ให้ครูหญิงบ้างอ่านครูฟ้าเนี่ยคิดถึงสระ
ว่ายน้ำครูหญิงก็คิดถึงอันนี้เลยค่ะโทรมา
อะไรคะผู้หญิง
ก็มีสระว่ายน้ำไปว่ายน้ำก็ต้องมีชุดว่าย
น้ำเห็นใช่ไหมคะเห็น 5 ชุดว่ายน้ำอะไร
บ้างคะเนี่ยชุดว่ายน้ำ S อยู่ไหนคะถ้า
อยู่นี่น้องชุดว่ายน้ำอันนี้เนี่ยเป็น
กางเกงว่ายน้ำราคานี้จะเป็นของผู้ชายผู้
ชายนะผู้หญิงแบบครูหญิงครูฟ้าเนี่ยไม่ได้
มั้ยก็จะมีชุดว่ายน้ำอันนี้วันพีชหรอ
วันพีช One  Piece นะคะกางเกงว่ายน้ำตัว
นี้ก็ผู้ชาย
แต่ถ้ามีนะครับเป็นว่ายน้ำแขนยาวเนาะเป็น
วันพีชแบบแขนยาวแล้วก็นี้เป็นผู้ Piece
นะคะมีเสื้อแล้วก็มีกางเกงชุดว่ายน้ำ
ไปสระว่ายน้ำต้องใส่ชุดว่ายน้ำใช่ไหมดีๆ
ไม่
สิ่งที่มีไม่มีรูปพี่กินี่ครูป๊าครูฟ้า
คิดถึงอะไรอีก
ครูฟ้าหรอคะ
ไม่ช้าผู้หญิงค่ะอ้าวมาได้แล้วมาก่อนใน
ภูฟ้าก่อนครูฟ้าคิดถึงอะไรฤดูร้อน
ฟ้าก็คิดถึงนะนี่ไง
พูดอะไรอ่ะอะไรใช่ค่ะ
ฮะโดนัทเหรอคะโดนัทอีกแล้วไม่โดนอีกแล้ว
คะสีฟ้าชอบโดนัทเนาะ
ห่วงยางหรอไม่ใช่ผู้หญิง
ครับลมๆ
พัดลงไง
เวลาร้อนใช่มั้ยก็เปิดพัดลมก็มีลม
[เพลง]
ร้านขายพัดลมขนม
โอเคเข้าใจกะครูหญิงบ้านครูหญิงบ้านครู
ฟ้าสต๊อกค่ะคปอ
ผู้หญิงอะไรจะว่าอะไรนี่ไงครูฟ้าโมราแบบ
ผู้หญิงขอ 2 อันนะคะครูฟ้าเวลาที่ฤดูร้อน
เนี่ย
เราก็ต้องคิดถึงอันนี้เลยค่ะ
อะไรคะฟ้ารู้ไหม
ร่ม
ปีเอาอ้าวแป๊บนึงแป๊บนึงค่ะขอร่มชายชาย
ให้รอมที่ทะเลปูแล้วก็ทะเล
ฉัน
ผู้หญิงเนี่ยกำลังอาบแดดค่ะครูฟ้ามีพระ
อาทิตย์แล้วก็มีแสงแดดใช่ไหมอ่าาานี้แดด
กำลังอาบแดดบาร์บีคิวทายค่ะบาร์บีคิวน้อง
อาบแดดหน้าต้องคิดถึงนักเรียนเนี่ยเวลา
ฤดูร้อนนักเรียนเนี่ยชอบไปอาบแดดไงคนไทย
ชอบไหมออกใหม่ใส่ไว้สอบใส่ค่ะไม่อยากรับ
เด็กทำดำจ่ายเฉพาะอาบแดดเนี่ยนักเรียนก็
ต้องมีอันนี้ไงภูฟ้า
อะไรคะ
ครีมกันแดด Banana  Boat
ทรายนี่ยี่ห้อ Banana  Boat ใช่ไหมครีม
กันแดดก็จะมี
SPF  50 เห็นไหมคะ pae เนี่ย + หมูอ้วก +
+  +
หาทรายก็ต้องมีครีมกันแดดค่ะค่ะอันนี้ครู
หญิงก็คิดถึงฤดูร้อนรู้ฟ้ามีอีกไหม
ครูฟ้านะคะอะไรเนี่ยเปลี่ยนเรียนบอกแม่
เรียนบอกเมาแล้วดูฟ้ากูฟ้า Share  screen
ผู้หญิง Share  Screen ไม่เมาไม่เมา
เมาส์ OK คิดถึงอะไรอ่ะลืมลงนึงนะเรียน
ฝ่ายคิดถึงเนี่ย
ปลาเหรอคะลาลา
อะไรอยากรู้ฟ้า
รู้ไหมนักเรียนครูฟ้าว่าอะไร
รู้เวลานะเรียนไม่ใช่โอลิมปิคนะเนี่ยใช่
นักเรียนบอกอะไรเป็นกลมกลมๆโอ้ว
อะไรคะครูฟ้า
มีต้นมะพร้าวถ้าจ่ายต้นมะพร้าวหอเวลาฤดู
ร้อนครูฝาก็คิดถึงต้นมะพร้าวถึงเกาะผู้
หญิงขอ
ฝากคิดถึงต้นมะพร้าว
เกาะใช่มั้ยแล้วก็ได้เป็นทะเล
เหมือนเกาะสมุยเกาะฮาวายใช่ไหมเกาะมัลดีฟ
นะคะเป็นเกาะเกาะเกาะเกาะในอยู่นี่ Baby
shark นะ Baby นี้ชัดจริงๆไม่ต้องการนัก
เรียนไม่อยากฟังเวลาฤดูร้อนครูฟ้าก็คิด
ถึงเกาะสมัยบนเกาะก็มีต้นมะพร้าว
ต้นมะพร้าวอย่างงี้มันเกราะเกราะ
เกาะรักเรียนบนเกาะฮาวายและเกาะกลาย
อะวายค่ะ
โอเคค่ะเข้าใจแล้วก็
ไม่ได้แล้วผู้หญิงค่ะของผู้หญิงบ้านให้
อัดรูฟ้าคิดถึงเกาะใช่ไหมคะ
ครูหญิงก็คิดถึงอันนี้ค่ะเวลาฤดูร้อน
คิดถึงอะไรคะผู้หญิงนี่ค่ะ
ดอกทานตะวันใกล้ screw ฟ้าอันนี้คือดอก
ทานตะวัน
ฤดูร้อนประเทศไทยก็เหมือนกันนะประเทศไทย
เนี่ยฤดูร้อนก็จะมีดอกทานตะวัน
น้อง
สวยมากผู้หญิงสวยแล้วก็ใหญ่ใช่ไหมคะเท่าๆ
หน้าครูหญิงอาจจะใหญ่กว่าหน้าครูหญิงนะ
ดอกทานตะวันนะคะ
ครูฟ้ามีอีกไหมคะฤดูร้อนที่ครูฟ้านี้
เนี่ยคิดถึง
มีฮะเกาะต่อไปค่ะเพราะว่าที่นี่นะพี่ผู้
หญิงคิวสอน
ไหน
บ่ไม่เห็นอ้ะเหรอกรุงสาวัตวัดแค่ที่นี้นะ
คะ
โอเคตรงนี้ว่าได้ไฟฟ้าคิดถึงอะไรฤดูร้อน
อีกอย่างหนึ่ง
ฤดูร้อนเนี่ยครูฟ้าคิดถึง
อีกแล้วนะคะสี่เหลี่ยม
อะไรคะตู้เย็น
ตู้เย็นได้เปิดมามีโค้กมีแป๊บซี่มีสไปรท์
มีไอศครีม
เย็นเย็น
นักเรียนเวลาอากาศร้อน 1 ฟังจะเดินไปที่
ตู้เย็นบ่อยๆนะฮะเปิดเย็นดูว่า The
scream มั้ยว่าเปิดตู้เย็นร้อนเนี่ยนอน
แล้วก็เลยเปิดตู้เย็น
ตู้เย็นๆใช่ไหม
ตู้เย็นหน้าฟรีตู้เย็น
อากาศร้อนนะของครูปะขออีกหนึ่งอย่างได้
ไหมคะครูฟ้า
มั้ย
โอเคได้ค่ะครูหญิงเนี่ยคิดถึงประเทศนัก
เรียนนะผู้หญิงก็คิดถึงกันปิกนิกใจไหม
เวลาฤดูร้อนเนี่ยนักเรียนก็จะไปที่สวนมี
ผ้า
ทำไมมีอาหารมีตะกร้านี้นะคะตักราดสมัย
แล้วก็ไปปิกนิกในฤดูร้อนคนไทยไปปิกนิกฤดู
ร้อนไหมคะ
คนไทยไม่ค่ะตาย
ทะเบียนชัยค่ะก็นักเรียนเอ้อฤดูร้อนเขา
คิดถึงอะไรบ้างก็คอมเม้นท์บอกเราได้นะคะ
วีดีโอนี้เนี่ยผู้หญิงกับกูฟ้าก็ต้องไป
ก่อนนะคะแล้วเจอกันวีดีโอหน้าบ๊ายบาย
สวัสดีค่ะอ่ะ